[Applaudissements]
ce soldats rentrent tout juste de la
ligne de front à l'est de barnique
nous leur tirons dessus à l'artillerie
et il réplique nous sommes en train de
les repousser ça se passe bien
depuis ce bâtiment on peut apercevoir
les soldats Ukrainiens qui installent un
mortier
regardez nos gars sont au boulot
après des mois sous les obus les civils
passent sans réagir
il faut partir maintenant
que faites-vous ici il va y avoir des
frappes
la bataille fait rage à un kilomètre à
peine
les Ukrainiens se sont préparés à
défendre le centre-ville
on vient de creuser les tranchées nous
on fait les finitions nous avons créé
des meurtrières juste au cas où il
viendrait ramper jusqu'à nous histoire
d'avoir de bonnes positions de tir
[Musique]
les Ukrainiens sont en train de creuser
des tranchées et de fortifier toute la
ville de bar Mount ils veulent être
prêts si jamais les Russes progressaient
leur objectif est clair conservez
backmouth coûte que coûte